[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tombs of
terror got another kind of disturbing
one uh for you today
so back in i believe it was early
2020 it seemed like this book by an
author called samantha clyesnick uh her
debut novella true crime was
everywhere it got like a huge huge
amount of buzz in the horror community
and even though i have to say i'm i've
successfully avoided like seeing any
synopsis or any reviews of it prior to
reading the novel for myself uh it was
hard to avoid seeing its quite awesome
cover by the way uh popping up in
youtube thumbnails and in horror book
review groups that i subscribed to and
things like that on multiple social
platforms so because of all the hype i
had been wanting to read it for ages
so i was pretty stoked when i saw it
come up on kindle unlimited to read for
free now it's not long it's actually i
guess technically it would be classified
as a novella i think it's only about 143
pages long so it pretty much only took
me like a single afternoon uh to read it
now i should note too that the author
samantha uh cole yes nick hopefully i'm
pronouncing that right i was like
listening to brian keane's podcast with
her on it to make sure i got her name
right because i hate like when people
like i hate like mispronouncing people's
names
so i try not to and i'm sure i've done
it like lots of times but i try not to
because you know that's just one of my
things uh but yeah so i guess she kind
of started out this is her first novel
and i think she's written another one
since then like another novel called
waif but prior to that she was kind of
actually mormon as like known as like a
film director like she directed shorts
and uh i think she's one of the people
that did like the women in horror like
film festival and stuff like that so
she's kind of been around and she's like
written screenplays and stuff like that
but this is actually her first novella
and it made like a huge huge splash like
in the horror community when it came out
back in early 2020. of all the reviews
that i've read of it subsequently like
after i've read it uh comparisons to
jack ketchum's the girl next door uh as
well as survivor by jf gonzalez are
pretty ubiquitous like pretty much every
review including this one now i
mentioned those comparisons i've also
seen a few reviewers compare it to um
the movie natural born killers at least
in the book's first act
uh these analogs are i will say like all
pretty accurate but true crime kind of
has a lot more going on than that it's
like slightly different it's got a
slightly different take on things but
that's kind of in the ballpark you know
what i mean so if you're kind of like
not down with that kind of stuff then
maybe you wouldn't like this either but
i'm just kind of giving that like as a
heads up to say
hey you know
if you were like really like traumatized
by the girl next door like pretty much
everybody then this is along those same
lines you know what i mean so yeah so
just a heads up it's like you know
trigger warning whatever the hell you
want to call it i wouldn't call it
extreme horror exactly
but it is very
grim very bleak kind of nihilistic
it's kind of intense it's very
disturbing so if you're really not down
with reading pretty realistic depictions
of like cold-blooded murder
animal cruelty there's kind of uh quite
a bit of animal cruelty in this and also
horrific sexual abuse targeted towards
children teenagers um as well as
essentially spending the entire story
inside the head of a sociopath then you
might want to give it a pass because
there are some kind of things that take
place in here some scenes in here that
you probably wouldn't want hanging out
in your brain from now on
it is a brilliant book i will say that
but it is not a fun time in other words
so just know what you're getting into uh
like i said it's beautifully written
it's very affecting but it's not the
kind of book that you like enjoy
necessarily like i said it's not really
a good time so just know that going into
it so at the beginning of the story we
meet our main protagonist a teenage girl
named susie
and she lives in this tiny little
[ __ ] of a town with her mother who's
only ever referred to as mama and her
older brother lim i don't i'm not
entirely sure if they say like exactly
how old these two are but i'm assuming
they both live at home and they both
seem like they're still teenagers
now susie at first um you know the first
part of the book is very obsessed with
this magazine called true crime which is
kind of like the old school kind of like
true crime magazines used to be
and from the first few paragraphs of
this book
the reader is made very aware that
something is
the matter with susie like that there's
something kind of like off about her uh
particularly in regards to
the way that she she reacts to like some
of the victims of the photos in her
magazines like she seems to have like an
obsessive
um kind of fixation
on the images of the female victims like
in the magazine um and seems to kind of
perceive women's bodies in that sense as
objects in a particular way and she does
seem to get a little bit
of a sexual charge from it you know i
mean it's not overt
but that's kind of like uh the
impression that you get
now not long after this we learn exactly
why susie is the way she is
uh since she can remember she has been
subjected to
pretty appalling sexual abuse at the
hands of her mother
who pretty much not only personally
assaults her daughter like on a regular
basis but also recruits her boyfriends
to do the same like sushi essentially
pimps her daughter out and she also kind
of like makes weird little things like
making her brother like look at her
boobs and [ __ ] like that it's like it's
[ __ ] up you know what i mean that's
what i'm saying it's [ __ ] up um so
susie in her entire life has never
experienced love or compassion she's
only ever been used and violated and so
that's pretty much literally the only
experience that she's ever had of the
world and the people in it
now she does think of her older brother
lim as her protector which he
technically is although lim as a person
almost kind of seems like a blank slate
it seems as though he is someone who
because he is you know
involved in the same situation obviously
and you're led to believe that he has
been abused as well
um so his kind of way of dealing with it
it seems is to completely disconnect
from all of his emotions other than rage
perhaps um in order to cope with what's
going on
or it's you know it could be that he
never had those emotions in the first
place um you know so it could be either
one of those things
uh but his instincts toward his sister
do appear to be those of like uh of a
fierce guardian type of thing
um and he will basically you know maim
or kill anyone who simply looks at her
or talks about her the wrong way
now susie makes it pretty clear on
several occasions during the narrative
that she
admires her brother a great deal uh one
because everyone is terrified of him
because he's really really scary
and two because he almost seems
invincible like she perceives him as
invincible which i guess would be a
common thing for
uh you know a brother-sister kind of
dynamic in this way like in growing up
in this abusive household like i'm
assuming that that's kind of how you
would perceive your older brother now
during one particularly distressing
uh session of abuse at the hands of her
mother susie finally snaps and uh beats
the woman to death
after which lim suggests that they set
the house on fire and skip town
now it should be mentioned here that at
some point in the recent past
mama had kidnapped a young girl named
alice
and kept her chained in the basement
now susie who had sometimes i guess been
comforted by talking to the captive
alice like through this air vent in her
room
briefly considers rescuing the kid from
the flames
but then
shrugs that impulse off and so her and
lim simply leave alice there to burn to
death with really nothing but the barest
twinge of regret
so as should be apparent from that last
sentence that i just said
susie as a character is frighteningly
sociopathic
but the thing that makes her
terrifying
is that she isn't portrayed the way
sociopaths are often portrayed in
fiction that's why i kind of think that
comparisons of this book like to natural
born killers are maybe a little bit off
the mark
like you know in natural born killers
mickey and mallory seem to kind of like
revel in their cruelty and their
sociopathy and they're represented that
way in the movie because the movie was
trying to make a statement about how the
media sometimes tends to romanticize or
glamorize people like that to some
extent susie on the other hand is kind
of a different kind of animal altogether
she doesn't necessarily seem to enjoy
violence in the strictest definition of
the word more in line with a true
sociopath i think she doesn't really
seem to enjoy much of anything
since all of her emotions it seemed have
been kind of like dulled down and numbed
by years of traumatic abuse she's
basically like a hollow shell of a
person
who sees other human beings particularly
women as things they're just a
collection of parts to be used as needed
and discarded um and it's obvious too
that she thinks of herself in this same
way
um she sometimes contemplates like
cutting off her breasts or like scooping
out her own genitalia she doesn't really
seem to have any fear
of physical pain for herself or death
for herself she just seems
almost just very cold like a little bit
indifferent like i said as you would be
like somebody that had experienced what
she experienced now she like she'll
occasionally comment for example that
she finds a woman beautiful
but in a way
that makes her want to take that woman
apart and see what's inside you know
what i mean she also seems to have
really no use for men in general except
for her brother she pretty much
perceives them all as predators uh that
can be again like used and killed as
necessary so after susie and lim like
flee their home after burning it down
they're on the run for a bit uh going on
something of like a mini killing spree
now although again many people compared
this segment of the book to natural born
killers the tone isn't really the same
at all uh yes they do kill people
usually for
this is gonna sound like weird but
usually for kind of like practical
reasons at least at first like they need
to steal money or they need to steal a
car or they need a place to stay or
something like that now occasionally
they do indulge in what seems to be a
murderous whim but they aren't exactly
like partying about it if that makes any
sense you know what i mean like if you
think of
you know like
in other words these aren't like these
kind of gleefully vicious like rob
zombie characters you know what i mean
like it's not like a baby from you know
like house of a thousand corpses or uh
you know devil's rejects or anything
like that where they're having like a
good time and they're like obviously
like reveling in their monstrosity i
guess honestly i think that's what makes
lim and susie in this book like even
more disturbing they know that they're
monsters they know what they're doing is
bad
but they're so
dispassionate they're kind of killing
more in a hey wouldn't it be interesting
if we ran this woman over like after we
steal her car like for no reason really
they didn't have to they were just
interested or mainly susie was just
interested to see what would happen and
then like after they do it she's just
kind of like huh and then that's kind of
like all she thinks about it like she
doesn't really think about it any that
much anymore so it's just kind of like
to me that's like what makes it scarier
because it seems like a lot more
realistic i mean obviously i'm not a
sociopath but i can imagine that this is
realistically like what goes on in their
heads so i think they're aloofness about
all of these situations it what makes
the whole thing seem a lot more genuine
a lot more realistic and hence a lot
more troubling and i'll note here too
that the whole kind of the whole entire
tenor or the whole entire mood of the
book is also somewhat muted as well in
its impact like a lot of disturbing [ __ ]
happens in the book but it's almost kind
of like some very ghastly things that
happen in the book almost seem to be
kind of glided over with very little
fanfare like you know what i said like
where they just ran over this woman and
they were just kind of like huh well you
know that's what happened you know what
i mean but i kind of feel like that's to
be expected because we're seeing things
through susie's eyes we're seeing things
it's like you know first person it's
from her pov and that's how she sees the
world so that's kind of how it's going
to come across in the book as well now
lim and susie's flight doesn't actually
last all that long however because
something happens that ends up landing
limb in prison
and after that we jump ahead two years
now susie who was perceived to have been
kind of dragged along on lim's escapades
against her will
um has actually been placed in uh with
kind of an understanding i'm assuming
like a foster couple or somebody that's
you know
taking care of her and like mentoring
her and stuff and she does seem to be
receiving or had received in the past
some kind of rudimentary mental health
care
so it's here i think where the story got
even more
uh compelling for me because it starts
to kind of explore some more
uncomfortable questions about people
like susie
like was she born the way she was and
then the abuse just exaggerated what was
already there
or did the abuse alone mold her into the
monster that she subsequently became can
she be helped can she be taught to be
normal like if she's around people who
are genuinely compassionate and
genuinely trying to help her so the
answers that the book give they don't
really give any answers because i mean
it's just very equivocal but this part
of the book is also also actually like
really tragic
because not only has susie's horrible
horrible childhood
taken away like any sense of right and
wrong that she may once have possessed
but
it's also made her
distrustful of everyone and unable to
understand or deal with anyone showing
her kindness she always thinks that
someone that everyone is out to get her
and that if you're showing her kindness
it must be like a way to get at her like
a way to [ __ ] her over somehow because
that's all she's ever experienced she's
so used to
being victimized that she sees everyone
as victimizers of one sort or another
and it's kind of hinted in the book that
this very effect of her lingering trauma
may pretty much doom her forever like
there's maybe nothing that can be fixed
you know what i'm saying so as i
mentioned earlier this is absolutely not
a fun read at all so it's just not like
hey i'm going to like lay on the beach
and read this on vacation or something
like that it's nothing like that but it
is a very harrowing read and it's very
provocative and i kind of feel like
that's because it deals more
realistically with a murderer who was
seemingly made fat by her horrific
circumstances and it also kind of
explores the way one person's trauma can
sort of like metastasize
to a point where it's affecting society
at large or at least like the small bit
of society that's just like in her
immediate vicinity you don't condone
susie's actions of course but because
you as a reader are kind of privy to
what she went through as a child or can
imagine it and you know her inner
thoughts since the narrative is told
from her perspective you can actually
sympathize with her to some degree and
you can also despair
at how
her past actually ended up shaping
these thought and behavior patterns
to the detriment of everyone around her
like it made like society made her a
monster and she seems like kind of aware
of it but she also doesn't really seem
to
know any other way to be because that's
the only thing that she's ever
experienced like i said
and also i think it's tragic too because
she does seem to have some very very
embryonic notions of
human empathy like she's not a complete
cold-blooded monster like she does seem
to have twinges of guilt or twinges of
maybe i shouldn't do that or something
like that so you do actually as it goes
on you do kind of start to root for her
like to you know kind of hope that
she'll be able to overcome
this corrupted nature you know what i
mean but
i you know the book doesn't really seem
to pull any punches in that regard it
seems to imply
that it's maybe too late for her um that
maybe she's too far gone
like to be redeemed which i kind of feel
like makes the story not only
frightening and but it's also like kind
of heartbreaking as well
um so i'm gonna say if you like the work
of jack ketchum in particular and maybe
are looking for something that uh is
again not not a fun time but something
that kind of delves into some really
dark corners
concerning the larger consequences of
trauma
and
literally puts you into the very
unpleasant headspace of a sociopath
without any kind of sentimentality or
embellishment or glamorization or
anything like that then i would
definitely recommend true crime it's a
pretty stunning uh debut novella i have
to say and uh the author this is
definitely uh someone that i'll be
keeping an eye on in the future so if
you've read it um let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this episode of
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
again on the next one bye